actuel
[musique]
avec nous en tant que bénévoles de l'information
avant s'est avéré tout réparer à cause de
notre passion du fait que nous
ramassé comme quelqu'un me l'a dit
la phrase a été arrachée par un pistolet d'information et
Levez-vous pour obtenir des informations
mettre la protection des informations de la patrie
sorte d'information
bouclier
[musique]
thème puissant mais je ne suis pas un soldat
guerre de l'information
[musique]
le soldat de la guerre de l'information permet
toi-même
beaucoup de choses que vous ne pouvez pas vous permettre
Reporter nous devons toujours à l'intérieur
réalité vérité rester
[musique]
que sous prétexte de protection nous devons
soit réduire notre activité, soit
changez votre rhétorique et restez généralement assis
ne brille pas, c'est-à-dire
[musique]